we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
hey
folks here we are we might be drunk we
are back
you got your npr outfit on that's nice i
love the sweater hey it's a winter baby
you got it you got to dress warm it
looks good you give a cocktail and a
pipe and a nice chair that's a good look
well and we are joined by our lovely
guest judy goldberg
new york love you guys hard working
comics my prediction is we break a peeve
record with yes
cause you you have a lot you're a
classic new york jew you have a lot of
peeves i just i [ __ ] hate people
like everyone's an [ __ ] and then this
pandemic you know what it made me
realize you know how like
people are like what was good about the
pen you know and i'm just like oh shut
up
the one thing i realized like not not
hanging out with my friends and then all
of a sudden
hanging out with them again oh
i'm like i hate you
you know what i mean like you're so
boring you repeat the same thing you
talk about yourself like right i can't
believe i spent so much time with you
well there was so much build up for the
hang too right right right right when we
hang and then the anticipation can't
wait to get together and then you're
like oh yeah it's like when there's a
new spiderman movie like another
spiderman then you see it you're like
that's the same [ __ ] wait ben my son and
his girlfriend said it was the best
spider-man movie ever i haven't seen it
i have heard it but there were like four
bad ones in between weren't there i've
given up there's too many it's like when
your friend keeps changing genders i'm
like i'm out
too money
but so that's your peeve is like you saw
friends and it's not even like you're
seeing him under great circumstances
right
right but it's also
like i think people
stop putting up with [ __ ] like you
realize wait i don't have to do that
right i don't have to do that i don't
have to do this
i this is way more fun than that like
you just like well everything's promoted
too no one goes to the office anymore
like we don't have to do that right [ __ ]
it and it changed the whole world right
and that's a good good example of what
you're talking about yeah yeah nobody
wants to go anywhere
i know i got so [ __ ] lazy didn't you
guys get lazy we got real lazy like i
would check my computer in the morning
like and if i had
anything to do i was like oh [ __ ] it's
tough you have to put on a bra like you
don't have to worry about that [ __ ] but
mark says the same thing he's
in the christmas i know they're looking
good though thank you i got a nice a my
ass
thank you should we do a drink now
oh my god beer jew we love you man thank
you all right today we're going to have
you want to go for tequila we're going
to do
kind of just like a classic mexican mule
oh yeah a little bit of black or tequila
there we go a little nice ginger beer
and a little lime oh oh i like that is
that okay you said not sweet but i hate
[ __ ] sweets exactly it's a little
it's a little spicy ginger beer is good
ginger beer is good we have nice ginger
beer we have fever tree here today not a
lot of sugar just like a little kick and
that's it a little longer yeah i don't i
don't want [ __ ] fruit in my [ __ ]
you know what i mean all that [ __ ] i'm
like
ain't gonna have attacking me thinking
it no no i want to see so girly and like
[ __ ] i don't yeah what do you what
are your drinks like you just have time
vodka tequila i love potato vodka what
does you like potato i love potato vodka
it's much smoother it's so much smoother
is that kettle one no it's like chopin
or belvedere any polish vodka yeah
um
and it's so smooth there's this one
called 1857 have you heard of it
so they make it in upstate new york on a
potato farm and they have like
um
you know they'll do like purple potatoes
they'll make it out of all and it's so
[ __ ] good we gotta get that yeah i
was gonna bring you a bottle and i
totally [ __ ] forgot like i forgot my
book [ __ ] potato [ __ ] is the only booze
irish people won't drink they're like
potatoes that is [ __ ] good not bad
wow
this ain't a game judy he's a mixologist
you know judy when i heard you were
coming on i was like all right i'm not
gonna make any fruity or like you know
sweet drinks we're going to go straight
for like a classic
mule really good he's a pro there you go
this is incredible and judy said you're
right which is a lover and you're
adorable thank you i try yeah and he's
and you know
mixologists i mean he makes literally
the best drink cocktail do you um do you
work at a
bar or anything or you're just like yeah
i work at a few different bars and i
work for a mixology company called
liquid lab
wow that's so cool yeah you should see
his sex tape hey
all right
so uh uh what else is that how about how
i went like that
that was hot you could say a sex tape
but i'm like yeah
bring it on what else is bothering you
anything else uh-oh okay last night pull
up why am i even putting this down
because i'm gonna drink the whole
[ __ ] thing
okay
i have so many things that are pissing
me off but
last night i did this gig right
it was i was hosting
an award show
at
a retreat you know for like
employees
and
first of all the driver who was so nice
i i wasn't even gonna tell you this but
this is so [ __ ] you okay we're
driving there and he's like yeah i got
the radio i got it siriusxm whatever you
want i i was like i don't care because
i'm like talking about the phone [ __ ]
yeah
where where is he taking you where's the
gig uh it was at the city winery in
hudson valley oh
yeah it was the bait it was the all
their employees from all over the
country valley is beautiful beautiful
stunning right but you know on the
throughway the exits are like a half an
hour apart right oh boy so we're driving
and
um i didn't really give a [ __ ] about the
radio but then all of a sudden he
changes the station
and it's tom papa and i go
i know i can't i can't he's my friend i
can't and then he turns another station
it's raw dog i go no
it's bobby kelly it's just people you
know
again you're like
come on what the hell right so he
reaches for the stereo right and he as
he's turning the dial
he hits the brakes and i realized he
missed the [ __ ] exit
and the next exit is [ __ ] three hours
away it was like half an hour so we had
to go to new paltz and then and [ __ ]
turn around and i'm just like
yeah right
all right so then i do this gig it was
real it was actually really fun because
you know when you don't have to do stand
up and you can just riff yes and you're
just like well let's not act like that's
nothing you know a lot of people want to
do their act because the riffing is
terrifying well the riff right exactly
and for me
it's yeah i know you're the same way
i don't know how if you're that way what
with the riffing uh yeah rifle i get so
bored with my act right so i have to but
but for me i get excited about like i'm
like really like if someone gets off
stage and says they suck
like for me i'm like yes like it's such
a challenge like i [ __ ] love that
really i don't like that i love that
because if it
i feel like
it's more pressure if someone gets off
before you and is like oh they're
[ __ ] great good point
they get off they're like smell my
finger that was amazing
no it's the worst i mean
i'm with you i and you are fun to watch
for a bad crowd oh i [ __ ] love it
it's my favorite the best um
so and it's so interesting because i
still haven't gotten to the peave but
whatever the the um
you know you know how everyone's doing
like crowd work albums and i'm doing
crap like when i started in the 80s
um
i would do imc'd a lot when i first
started because i wanted to be really
comfortable on stage
which were the rooms you emceed in oh my
god comedy you grand
uh comedy you
yeah it was called comedy paul herzeg
ran that right yes oh my god that's
where a tell went on stage for the first
time i was standing in the back i was
i'm singing
yes he had hair he was an nyu student he
came in he went on i remember he had
this [ __ ] hilarious joke about um
uh oh everyone has anorexia now it was
right when everyone was saying they have
anorexia yeah he goes the other day i
was walking by me i don't this is not
the exact wording but i was walking by
macy's
uh
uh
i was walking by macy's and in the
window was a mannequin with her finger
down her throat it was a [ __ ]
and he got upset remember i was like you
were so [ __ ] funny he's like no not
i [ __ ] love these guys so um that's
great yeah so i used to emcee
uh the first year i did stand up i
started when i was 19. but the first
year i did it i couldn't talk to the i
was too scared and then everyone's like
just you know
be and so emceeing real and that was
when the mc
was
uh respected
you know what i mean it wasn't like
we're gonna take the least
um
seasoned comic and make them the mc the
first thing the crowd sees is the is a
newbie right the right bone of the show
also
if you emcee you learn how to bring a
crowd back deal with any [ __ ] that goes
on in the room you you can isolate your
bits that was the best part i could be
like oh i got to do a couple minutes
because this one but [ __ ] bombs and
you could take your bits and they would
stand alone you know in the show right
and i remember and when i started and i
would hang out a catch and like belzer
would be an mc yes
and how old are you
59
you look great
but bells are you know all the mc's at
catch
they would start at like eight o'clock
and go to maybe 11 30 and then they'd
have a late night emcee
um and the show went until like two in
the morning
oh my god
it was all we people were there there
was a band it was really a magical time
i'm telling you oh and bells it was an
incredible emcee yes but the mc was the
star of the show was like their show and
they [ __ ] got rid of that and you
know i'm sorry but
it is
the most important
they set the tone i like it i like when
the mc i think in other places they
respect that more but like canada but
yeah but when you exactly but when you
see a host like like uh i tell you that
thing the insomniac tour and he hosts it
right
i think there's something cool about
being like i'm introducing all these
comics this is my show right and that's
the way it used to be and like i i think
within a couple years ago i i hosted
something at the village underground i
don't know who it was it was jeremy or
red or or liz i don't know who someone
was there is like oh my god and i'm like
i used to emcee all the time yeah you
know
it it you feel like and as a comic you
feel like wow this audience is ready to
listen
um but here's the problem they go you
want to host tomorrow you go [ __ ] no no
there it is but it wasn't like here it
was like you it was it wasn't easy to
get from one club to another like to be
able to get on stage all night oh that's
a good point you know
um and plus for women
like
they never put more than one woman on a
show if they put a woman on a show so i
was like i just want [ __ ] stage time
i don't care so the other hosts were
like joy behar right and joy
um i learned so much from watching them
um who yeah who are the male hosts back
in the day who we might know cohen oh
mark mark cohen definitely for me mark
cohen's got one of the best jokes i've
ever heard where he says uh you know a
guy a cop knocks in a guy's door he says
we're looking for a rapist the guy goes
all right i'll see what i can do
that's an incredible joke incredible
that's the best kind of misdirect such a
such a funny yeah i love marcon i'll see
what i get
who else um oh my god who else you gotta
start think uh naming people i remember
ray ray used to come romano oh my god he
would emcee no but he would come to the
show
at comedy you grand
and his wife anna would be i was friends
with anna and she would be like he was
delivering futons at the time i think
and
she was like i mean how long
can he continue to do this i want to
have a family wow and i was like
yeah wow you never know oh my god
michael chiklis you know michael chiklis
the shield
he was the bartender at comedy u grand
right
oh my god he was the nicest guy so
and you know the mc hangs out we hung
like that was the other thing we hung
you gotta hang so michael was the emcee
and he had this girlfriend and and uh he
really loved her
and her father convinced her to break up
with him because oh he's just a
bartender actor
right yeah and he was so depressed and
then he got this john belushi part whoa
uh in a movie and he left and became
you know this and i remember thinking
and one of the hotter bald guys i feel
like yeah yeah yeah it's hard to be like
a bald sex symbol but like bruce willis
pulled it off right he pulled it yeah
now anyone could but back then yeah that
was rare well bulb white guy oh there
were
black sex symbols well i remember when
he got this part and i was like oh my
god see [ __ ] her [ __ ] her and her father
and
and he then became you know this huge
star and when i if i see him on a set
it's like old time you know what i mean
that's like the
uh yeah so anyway also idris elba was
the bouncer
i love that there was like a huge thing
now saying like they're like there's
people really pissed that he's in the
running for bond because he's black and
i'm like this is not woke [ __ ] he would
be the coolest bond yeah what is
everyone's [ __ ] problem it's also i
saw one guy respond i read some of the
tweet replies sometimes because they
make me laugh they're like yeah what's
next a white roots i'm like slavery was
real
there's a difference
they did a black kid in spider-man and
it's the best spider-man movie oh they
used it that's like the only really good
spider-man for my mind if i was drunk
when i tweeted that
yeah but i'll say like andrew zelber's
like the coolest [ __ ] oh my god
luther is incredible yeah
i mean whether or not you like obama
coolest president
[ __ ] plays basketball like sorry i
never thought i'd live long enough to
see a [ __ ] president just drain a
three from the corner
and
knowing that he and his wife [ __ ] like
right oh absolutely don't you think i
think they probably [ __ ] yeah did you
guys not see the sex tape
[Laughter]
all right so back to our wait so what oh
wait i wanted to make this point i'm
good i know i'm trying not to guzzle it
down we got more don't worry guzzle it
make the point about why do you get a
glass
yeah these are better for their workers
these are these are made for the mules
this is for the poppers backstage glass
make a [ __ ] difference with the taste
of it all right so technically
[Music]
there is a little like urban myth about
i'll be real quick but the urban myth
about it is that
the way the mule the moscow mule with
vodka came about first was there's some
three guys in a bar in san francisco
right this is just another myth no way
to you know verify it but that's how
most drinks stories are uh one of them
just bought smirnoff vodka to try to
popularize it this is like the early
20th century everybody's drinking
whiskey and gin he tried to popularize
vodka didn't know what to do with it in
america
then the second guy next to him uh had
just bought a jamaican
ginger beer company and was trying to
use that as a mixer instead of ginger
ale and then the third guy for whatever
reason is surplus of copper i don't know
if you just raided someone's homes or
whatever but yeah
so the bar is the beginning of a street
joke
the third guy the first yeah a rabbi
so the bartender helped them kind of
like put all the ingredients together
and made uh the moscow mule but
technically uh
copper um kind of seeps toxins out of
uh
liquor or in your body as well wow so
it's supposed to be kind of like a
detoxifying drink because what i'm going
to say after i drive after drinking four
of these
yeah wait what about um stir versus
shaken
from martinis
yeah uh well let's say uh
i think all martinis should be stirred
unless specified otherwise the only time
you shake martinis is if somebody wants
a really really cold
uh martini with the what they call it
the pond on top yeah
the reason that james my little joke is
that the reason that james bond always
wanted his martini shaken not stirred is
because when you shake it it dilutes it
more so you have a weak technically a
weaker drink
you have much more water in there so
he's a spy and he has [ __ ] to do
so he doesn't want to be too [ __ ] up
so he gets it shaken
that's true but what about drinking
alone
i encourage you remember when when they
tried when smirnoff was the official
vodka for james yeah we were all like
we're not buying it yeah yeah james bond
is ordering goose or bella he's not
ordered yeah that's that's absolutely
this that that was completely insane
i'll do another one of these here's the
cool let's do it
yeah
the other thing is
you know this is another thing that
[ __ ] pisses me off when i say i want
i still have a little bit left when i
say i want potato vodka and they're like
oh tito's i'm like tito's is corn you
[ __ ] [ __ ] is pretty good though i
think and the hangovers
cheetos is fine i think it's a good like
mid-tier vodka i honestly if you can
find it i do prefer potato vodka yeah
really
show pot it is a lot smoother the
starches of it makes it a lot smoother
and especially in a martini it's
fantastic yes that's what i do
by the way shaken one of my biggest pet
peeves is uh when you shake a dirty
martini
you should never shake a dirty martini
just because uh all that olive juice
just starts uh like bubbling up and just
like you just get like a whiff of olive
juice in your face when you drink it
and that's it this is how i order my
martinis every time
i say i want a martini
as dry as a 98 year old woman's vagina
every time and if the [ __ ] weight
person doesn't laugh i'm like we're out
of here
because sometimes they're like okay and
i'm like what
um all right back can i tell go back to
my story about brad work all right so
crowd work when i started like
everyone's like don't do crowd work
don't do crowd work and now i'm like
what the [ __ ] you know just have your
material you have to have your material
so you can put together a late night set
whatever and now everyone's doing this
crowd work [ __ ] yeah and it's like do
you realize you have to be good at that
like you can't just go hey you know it's
i think there's somewhere in the middle
though i think a lot of these people
just do a lot of crowd work they're
killing because crowd work does hit
harder right beyond the moment it's in
the room
so but if you can write a great joke
that'll live forever this is just it's
great it's nice but you can't hold on
mix but especially i don't like
following someone a host if they only do
crowd work because then if i'm on first
i'm like well i'm doing i'm doing the
first joke right right right
when i would host back in the day i used
to host the caroline's a lot which was
great for me because
you know oh thank you but uh you know
i i try to just go into material but if
they weren't biting on the jokes i would
do crowd work then go back and i would
try to get them on jokes for the first
comic
after me you have to have you have to
prepare them to listen yes you have to
disarm them you have to make them into a
unit yes like okay we're done ordering
drinks
the show is
you know about to start this is how we
do it and you don't shove it down the
throat you show them yeah you get them
in the mode of listening to some
material hey how you doing i hope the
drive-in was great blah blah blah
material material bring up the okay you
ready blah i agree and and it's like
yeah i mean like i want to kill ray
allen a lot
we're getting two inside
three people know that guy um no it's so
fun
okay can we talk about when we
we're at city winery uh-oh i think
you're gonna scold him for the bird for
a second and he's [ __ ] farting like
just farting and i'm like really
who's farting
mark oh oh right at the greenwood city
winery yeah yeah yeah we're sending us
and we're eating everyone's eating and
he's like oh excuse his party found
excuse me oh did i do that
rejected it left no you did it all right
okay so anyway back to my gig last night
this is my pet peeve
and i can't believe i'm even staying on
track because
all right
so i do this whole hosting thing
and you know they're all like in their
i guess they were all in their early 30s
maybe late 20s early 30s you know young
and hip right one of these guys like
after the show and i you know i killed
you know of course i mean i know how to
[ __ ] host a goddamn award show and
make fun of the anyway lesbians are
funny
i like that she made you sit in there
and
i've been trying to get a fart out right
on time
says shocking [ __ ] he is just trying to
cover up farts at all times but it's
also like i've heard everything i don't
even [ __ ] care but um i know
i get off stage and then all these
people are like oh can we take a selfie
right and then
[ __ ]
[ __ ] who runs city winery
i know that's a normal and i said this
on stage
that's just
also is the pitcher
in the israeli
baseball team in the olympics
and he i said
[ __ ] is the only good-looking [ __ ]
in the entire [ __ ] world anyway
so he's like
you want to get something to eat
there's no way that's a good baseball
team oh no they lost to mexico
south korea and
the united states the only team where
you're out for five to six days with
allergies
they're all american too they're all
jews who couldn't get on the united
states team anybody who said you never
hear about the israeli
there's a few jewish baseball greats
obviously right koufax sean green kent
greenberg yeah i think there'd be more
of them it's it's called the diamond
oh god you are on fire
baseball diamond come on i was proud of
that there right here
he's a hug
he's so hot i can't tell you man oh man
anyway
that's what they say when you give them
a diamond it's real
i liked it i'm bombing have you guys
ever been to thrill i wish i i was oh my
god it's [ __ ] great yeah
okay yeah so um so i finished the gig
you know and i'm walking and [ __ ] was
like oh you want something to eat so we
walk into some area where there's a
fireplace in a bar or whatever
and one of these guys who's like works
at one of the city winery somewhere he
looked like late 20s mid to late 20s and
he got and he says to me hey
you were pretty funny oh
that's a piece and i wanted to [ __ ]
i was pretty funny pretty funny's not a
compliment
to say hey b-minus right right everyone
else is like oh my god that was
hilarious like i totally [ __ ] ripped
apart the hr person and her staff came
up to me and said oh my god thank you so
much thank you so much because yeah
apparently she's very hr um and so
anytime i said something off color i was
like oh sorry
and
and then here's this [ __ ] [ __ ] guy
yep who's like
they're pretty funny it's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
you get up there you [ __ ] get up
there for one [ __ ] minute and see how
you you know it's just like well let's
be fair you just said about your kids i
kind of love them i i know
but i get it i get it i'm with you yeah
i love them i really i know i mean i
could go get gushy i love them so much
but pretty funnies and fury another
infuriating one is when someone goes up
to you and goes i thought you were good
oh my god
oh my god
so did the crowd did you hear
[ __ ] yeah killing [ __ ] you or i
i had one person say to me you were a
second favorite just tell me i was funny
the [ __ ] or what about when someone
comes up to you and says you were the
funniest and the other comics are
standing right [ __ ]
none of it's good just say just don't
say anything i also i would never do
that at a [ __ ] show i would never go
up to like uh broadway actors after a
show and be like you were number one
right right
guys you were great
right they always rank us it's brutal
why people like last comic standing they
don't want uh here's a bunch of funny
comedian showcases yes he was the best
she was the one time i owned for amy
schumer she was on stage killing i had a
solid set it wasn't great and then i was
[ __ ] in the bathroom at the denver
comedy works and i heard a bunch of guys
washing their hands oh she's so funny
man she's killing what'd you think about
the opener and they were like he sucked
and they're like three feet away from me
i'm [ __ ] my pen it's the most
vulnerable moment of my life when i go
i thought he was pretty good
[Laughter]
and they were like i don't know what
you're drinking man but he sucked and i
was like oh my god i never
like are you ever in the green room
after uh you go to the green room after
the show and you have a second show and
the audio's on oh as they're clearing
out and you're like no i don't want to
hear what they have to say no
like because you're just waiting for you
know that totally i see some guy going
the jews will not replace us oh my god
how was that i was drinking when i said
people do say
[ __ ] to comics that they don't say to
any other performers and no one respects
it they don't do that broadway it's like
everyone thinks they're funny everyone
no no one i've never heard someone
anyone say like i have a bad sense of
humor no one says that if i meet someone
who says that i'm like that's [ __ ]
honest right there yeah yeah i've never
heard it but also we don't have an
instrument so like right with an
instrument they go i can't play that so
right right right or something like that
well anyone who makes what they're doing
like
we all looked at like newscasters or
sportscasters or something been like
well that looks easy but that's a skill
oh yeah right especially calling a game
i mean yeah that ain't easy i mean you i
mean
if you put a person just on a game
calling it like that's a [ __ ] hard
thing to keep it entertaining to keep it
like you know insightful to comment on
what's going on oh i know and not miss
any
you know you you're like hyper focused
like we are on stage you know the minute
like you're on st especially if you do
theater like that's what there's another
thing don't [ __ ] put your goddamn
phone on when you're on stage and
someone pulls out their phone um it's
the only thing you see from the stage is
the [ __ ] light like and these people
are just [ __ ] [ __ ]
i love the seller they take the phone
they take the phones it's huge because
even if they're not taking a video
they're still thinking at a like a show
in the middle of nowhere they're like i
could text i could tweet right right oh
just thinking it right
and that that sucks too but when the
phones are gone they just they just
accept that and focus
plus
what was that
i guess my little tequila mule is
getting to me
yeah
sorry what oh no i want to ask you oh
hell yeah
[Applause]
who uh who are other comics you remember
like coming up with in the 80s that like
we might remember
i remember adam sandler getting on stage
really yeah and i remember louis
coming out
yeah and so he first he when i started
he was the bartender at catch rising
star
miranda yeah and then so luffy don't you
you know as you don't know listening he
was he's the booker at the legendary
caroline well now he and he started the
whole you know new york comedy festival
that was him i didn't know that him and
caroline very nice guy lewis yeah and
sarah
what she's hot huh
caroline yeah
yeah how can i bond with you you both
like the uh the labia why because she's
all like my agent no i mean i think
she's i've been hearing mark say this
for years i don't think this is she is
hot she is there we go there we go okay
i just burped by the way all right but i
held it in unlike you so
[Applause]
um she does feel like your mother right
now
lewis was the bartender yeah and then
so in in the mid 80s but you know there
were no cell phones and there was the
comic strip
there was
a catcherizing star there were all these
club there was the cellar there was like
green street there were all these clubs
and you had no cell phone so if you got
on the subway or you were in a cab
and you were late for your spot there
was no way oh right to tell you know to
contact the club you could go to a pay
phone or something right that was it so
uh they had catcherizing star had two
backups so you would sit at the bar um
you got paid 50 bucks which was what the
comics got to do with set
to just hang out in case someone didn't
show up but there were always comics who
didn't get spots or were doing spots at
the strip that would come in to sit you
know
and so they had two people who were the
backups got it and you just sit there
you got 50 bucks
and it was me
and chris rock wow
that's wild yeah
um late 80s mid 80s mid to late 80s yeah
was he nice uh i love him yeah
he's just a class act he was one of my
heroes he's [ __ ] hilarious
yeah he's brilliant i mean i mean he's
great his first role with the new not
his first born suspect was the first
album oh my god well with the new was
like the album that got me in the
comments is that right yeah
well i remember listening to it and uh
on a cd player and i probably got half
the jokes i was yeah
thank you yeah yeah my mom grabbed the
cd player like what's he listening to
him put the headphones on like an
overprotective mother and she starts
she starts listening and uh i remember
her face out of the gate was like horror
just horrible really and then she kept
listening for 30 seconds and she laughed
and i was like that's [ __ ] comedy
baby the fact that he pushed her away in
the setup right right
even then you knew i i loved that i
loved the power of a joke with that also
i mean i saw pryor's special in the
[ __ ] movie theater wow
oh live
in concert yeah live from that
strip yeah
wow
i mean first of all
you talk about comedy
and
you know all this
woke [ __ ] where you can't
say oh really i tried to muffle it
i'm listening everyone can hold their
[ __ ] parts in but yeah wow
i thought it would be good comedy
and i tried to totally she's literally
winding up for like a heavy point mark
she goes to think about what comedy
that's a little too strong i didn't
think
[Laughter]
you're censoring me
shut
why can't you hold in your farts i think
it's funny to let them out
it's a comedy show it is pretty funny i
mean it's not it's not uh i could hold
it in but
well nothing's respectful like is there
anyone in the world you wouldn't fart in
front of
if obama were in the room no
i think he would like it
he deals with the secret service all day
and his wife doesn't seem that fun
when's the last time you see michelle
obama crack a jew joke
all right anyway
i want to hear this
you know like richard pryor gets on
stage even after he blew himself up
right what's the first thing he talks
about
blowing himself up
exactly like no fear like george carlin
no fear the whole the whole bobby brown
bit uh or jim brown bobby brown holy
[ __ ] the whole jim brown bit in prior
sun says right special it's like what
you gonna do that whole day oh my god
this is like amazing this is like a
[ __ ] one-man show but it's got punch
lines i know i know that's what comedy
was richard pryors and now it's like
i don't know i can't i just i agree
that's why i yell at them all the time i
mean well the worst part is when comics
get mad you're like you know what this
is what are you doing i don't get why
you're yelling at me you're a comic
what's going on yeah i made a crazy joke
but
i'm a comic but it's also like
you take intent
context and nuance
out of the equation of course yeah and
that's the end it's like listen i now
get on stage and say i just want you to
know that none of the comics here
when they were writing their jokes
tonight were thinking about your [ __ ]
childhood trauma okay well said sorry
it's not about you but they're like
that's insensitive to these groups i
don't care like it's not listen to the
[ __ ] joke it's not i don't know you
have a joke i love about um about your
son wanting to get uh a tattoo he hates
that
her son wants to get a tattoo in the
joke and it's
their zip code
you're a jew you're not getting numbers
on your arms you're not doing it on your
arms that's a great joke that's
brilliant right he hates it he's like
mommy that was so losely
yeah whenever he was 18. he's not mad
about the the offensiveness he's bad
right right right accuracy but it's like
someone came up to me i did that joke
and someone like a jew uh who
and he's like you know that joke makes
me feel uncomfortable i'm like why it's
a true story it really happened yeah and
every night i get on stage and talk
about the holocaust so like what the
[ __ ] is your
there's nothing offensive about that
right the job the joke is he was saying
here's why you shouldn't do that right
right right so if anything you're the
voice of reason in the joke you yeah and
you can't everything people take [ __ ]
they make it their own own right and
it's all about whatever i think the joke
is exactly what it is and it's like no
it's the comedian who is telling the
joke has a purpose behind that joke and
an intention behind that joke it's not
about [ __ ] you and now i feel like
now when you write material
um i see this with a lot of comics
they'll
they they do the i want to make this
funny i want to talk about this i want
to make this funny and now we have that
extra
thing where we go oh this one's going to
think that the exact person is going to
think now you're changing art right and
it's like no that's not what i mean
right when you try to do a late night
set now the the way they neuter it is is
like it's like parody of itself wow
where you're like forget about you guys
realize that you were stripping any
point of view from the act now so now i
have to like there's nothing funny about
a person tiptoeing around a premise
you're taking the guts out of comedy
yeah
we don't want to do your [ __ ] show
unless you're going to let us do the
joke as written and right and otherwise
enjoy having neutered vanilla horse [ __ ]
on your late night show which guess what
is neutered vanilla horseshoe that's all
so you can't come in with your
interesting avant-garde [ __ ] because
it'll stand out don't turn me into you
well that's what they have to do
but yeah but i'm doing this in a [ __ ]
club for actual people you're doing this
for puppy dogs in a store right
this is what we should cut to our
sponsor there's no sponsors from iac
this segment was brought to you by uh
puppy chat
yeah no i'm with you it's crazy and then
they all sit around and go and they
praise prior and lenny bruce and george
carl and all this [ __ ] and you're like
you would have hated them you would have
never let them on prior's got like i
mean uh carlin's got like a bunch of
n-words in his act
did you know when george floyd was
murdered the number seven download on
spotify the following weeks was george
carlin's or no it was priors bit it was
i'm sorry it was priors bit about cops
versus ends because it's still relevant
right because it was still relevant oh
wow well you know what's interesting is
you know bill hicks is such a great oh
my god
i used to watch him really see him in
the well i was going to say hicks on
letterman they wouldn't era pretty oh my
god did you see that and that's all in
my book
pretty not edgy i mean it's edgy it's
got opinion and bite but it's not for
like you're like this you won't let
right let's go on tv
uh so that's pretty painful but uh you
so you work with bill hicks but this is
nothing new well i just you know he
would be at the you know a catch or
whatever he was [ __ ] brilliant but
it's also like
you know was he was he friendly to you
oh he was i loved him ah
sorry
uh no it's nice no i mean we i i've
talked to some people who like he's not
their cup of tea for me i think bill
hicks is one of the great oh great i
think he died at like 33.
that much great kind of started at 14 i
think he's bill hicks is brilliant yeah
you know there wasn't
you know the the community the there
weren't as many comics right sure and we
all had each other's backs there's too
many colors and i was telling you in the
cab the other day
you know it's it's sort of clicky now
big click very divided it wasn't like
that yeah you know i agree it's
especially you know when there were
times when people weren't get you know
at the comedy store
in the 70s and people you know bonded
together to get paid you know people
we were a unit and a community um bad
stuff forces us to come together right
but now it's like
comic used to be enough like we couldn't
be more different uh jewish lesbian
northeast southern [ __ ] farter you know i
fart all the [ __ ] time i just doesn't
know i don't do it well i defend i just
go oh i used to watch you on tough crowd
when i lived in new orleans like she's
funny that's all i i needed uh she's
coming you were one of the few female
comics in that world so that's right
you're not just you know
you're in a world that's
there aren't a lot of women out late at
night doing that stuff that you're doing
is that was that weird coming up in the
80s 90s early 2000s well yeah there
weren't a lot of us um there was a
comedy eugrande on thursday nights had
this show
oh and they used to advertise it all
female
comedians it was like okay really period
yeah there was always some horrific name
but it was all these women that
it was the one night we all got to work
together you know what i mean because we
never got to work together
um
and so
i don't know i mean i do remember
some comic some female comics i mean i
was so
you know i'm so focused like i just
wanted to be a good comic like that was
it
um and plus i didn't want to [ __ ] any of
the guy comics i was just like one of
the guys you know
and so i think
well we're so identity focused now yeah
yeah yeah i watched ellen i watched
paula poundstone i watched rita rudner i
watched carol burnett i watched i love
lucy and i was never like these are
funny women i was like these are funny
comments right right right now we're
just beating down where it kind of has
the opposite effect that it's supposed
it's supposed to be this progressive
kind of we're open we're inclusive but
now i'm like woman black gay
and now i just pick and i count
everything on the lineup i also just
wish you could just mix it all together
because like we're like a step away from
being like here's the best of comics who
don't know how they identify all stars
list we were just like but they do that
for like if they they you know oh here's
the problem that if you go to a comedy
show and it's just three guys it's an
emcee
a feature act and a headliner it's just
a comedy show if it's three women it's a
it's a it's an event it's an event if
it's three black people it's an event
that's a good one if it's three you know
hispanic or latin next people it's an
event you know and that's what the
[ __ ] problem is stop doing that it's
great it's funny you're either funnier
enough with themes the theme should be
is this good right yeah that's the theme
i'm i'm telling you there's a lot of men
and there's too many men you're like i
know but a bunch of men get into comedy
i know it's not mad at the men it's like
saying hey nba is 99 black what the hell
lebron he's like i just want to play
basketball why are you mad at me get mad
at the okay you're complaining that
there's that you're not i'm not
complaining that there's too many men
i'm complaining that we just want to be
comedians
so why uh why are we the best right but
that's you're you're feeling that now
right
you feel that now
imagine starting
like i used to call these clubs and they
would be like
you know i'd be like hi i'm judy gold
there's just an evening at the improv
and caroline's comedy hour blah blah
blah and they'd be like oh we had a
woman here three months ago and she
didn't do anything that's insane well
that's crazy yeah
that was the pressure i mean do you feel
the pressure when you're like trying to
work on a new album i never
but and then if you don't do well
they're like we're done with women yeah
i mean that's completely crazy and that
was what what it was like and it was and
it was like um
it's awesome yeah i i just and i always
was like i'm not it's not about me being
a woman it's just gonna be about me
being funny right um and then you become
a representative
plus which you didn't ask for right but
then i came out
on stage when henry was born i mean
everyone knew i was a lesbian but um but
then i have a kid and it's like every
comic talks about their friend like i'm
going to talk about my [ __ ] family
because i sort of came out as a gay
parent you know
um
and i was just like i can't do my act
i can't be true to who i am without
being true to who i am i feel like that
was like a thing like you couldn't just
say my family i mean you kind of have to
couldn't i can't lie you know can you
yeah no i couldn't [ __ ] live with
myself of course not no no i'm saying
like but do you feel like you're like
okay well now this is
i think i'm sure in the 90s it was a
harder thing to to just jump into maybe
not in the clubs but on tv maybe it was
oh my god it totally had a major effect
ellen ellen got kicked off tv basically
yeah exactly and this was
clubs were much more i think crowds when
they see you and they know you but when
you have five minutes to kill and you're
introducing yourself like and people are
a little you know
provincial i mean that's that's right
and you have to like say
oh i'm you know you ha you can't the
joke doesn't work unless you know i'm a
big less you know
um and so it was you had to say it like
sometimes now i'll do a joke and i'll
have to say oh i forgot to tell you it
was a less you know like
[Laughter]
[Music]
but i i it was never like that you know
but my friend bob smith god rest us all
he
uh was the first out uh gay comic on
that on the tonight show oh really yeah
yeah remember rob smith funny yeah and
he was my best friend he died of als but
um
he was he would he looked like jimmy
stewart you know like he was just this
all-american kind of guy
and he he does his material and how he
came out was
um
he would say
i
the joke was i made my carefully worded
announcement at thanksgiving
uh i said to my mother can you please
pass the gravy to a homosexual
she passed it to my father
[Laughter]
and it was like here's this you know
like handsome tall white
all-american
e kind of guy pull him up man pull up a
picture of him oh he was the [ __ ]
was it comedian yeah bob smith comedian
i remember him he did a lot of tv oh
yeah there he is oh he is handsome uh uh
yep oh yeah yeah he's a great head of
hair punk
just a hunk and then and he wrote five
bucks there he wow with the als horrible
he wrote a book
um his last book called treehab
he literally wrote
um
he had an ipad and he would he couldn't
use his
he couldn't use his fingers he would
drop his one letter at a [ __ ] time oh
his books are so good he was wow
he was an amazing joke look at him look
how cute
i was today i'd blow him
what um
i thought it was a compliment like do
you think a comic would get annoyed
about that now like uh probably yeah of
course what do you suck
i mean that's that's fascinating like
that's the thing with you know it's so
hard for me because i'm so used to this
kind of talk you know what i mean that's
why we had you on no but it's like and
i'm like okay shut the [ __ ] up and now
it's like
well here's the problem
you get clout for calling out so like i
don't even know if they actually are
it's a jumping off point it's a jumping
we got him that he said that thing about
blowing the dead
what do you think about yeah i mean so
your book is about you're a little
annoyed with this like uh the woke
mindset it's about the fact that
we're just trying to make you laugh like
sure and so if you were if you murdered
someone right and you go on trial for
homicide your sentence is determined by
your intent what you were thinking what
your motive is right and yet you don't
give the same consideration to a
comedian writing a joke right that was
involuntary joke slaughter right exactly
i'm with you there's something very
interesting about and look if in your
heart this woke mindset if that's really
who you are and that's i i'm happy to
talk to you and i right
but a lot of it does feel performative
and like a pat on the back right where
you're like look at me it's virtue
signaling like if it's not real you can
tell right you know
it's your act also
you know
i
am an activist i fight for people's
right like i'm not just someone who goes
on stage and tells jokes like i will
speak out for the things that are right
you know it's just i don't know well
there's real problems and i think
attacking a comic is easy you know right
it's right there you know who said it
you can tweet about it immediately you
can call them a racist but like
they won't actually there's women's
clits getting cut off they won't help
them right that actually takes some
calorie burning well yeah i i have been
attacked for jokes before and i'm kind
of like well what have you done that
actually right right right yeah because
you're kind of like you're you're yeah
it always and they're not perfect either
they're flawed as well but they just
aren't you know they're not convinced
right and it's also like we're just
comedians until we say something that
pisses you off then we're dangerous
it's like you go to i write about this
too in the book like i had a friend who
went to i forgot what concert and uh she
was so excited and it was an all-new
album
and she was like oh [ __ ]
you know
like i wanted to hear the greatest hit
of course and she left there still
loving the band
right but
[ __ ]
but for us who we do our work in front
of an audience you know what i mean good
point we don't know where the line is
until we cross the line
and you know the audience tells us it's
this one art form it's like you're not
an artist who create oh
who creates um judy's book like you
don't yes
like you know you're not drawing a
[ __ ] landscape right yeah and you're
half or a third of the way done and then
you invite friends over so what do you
think of the sun what do you think of
the tree what do you think should i move
this over there no it's the only art
form where we you know the audience
informs us okay that's not gonna work
there we need to take that syllable out
okay there's no painters like what do
you think about this stroke right right
right right exactly exactly right and
it's so
you know you want to be a part of this
process and then you get [ __ ] pissed
off at us no and george carlin said it's
the comedian's job to cross that line
and make you glad that they did i love
you know yeah so true and do you want to
ruin art
like i know it bothered you
but it made a thousands or hundreds of
other people very happy laughed they had
a hard day so we just got to focus on
you that you were right but we don't but
we don't and it's we i'll say we cater
to them but we don't the oscars they're
gone you don't you don't i
sure the room but they've been ruined
for years i mean they've fallen off long
because of this but we also
i don't know i think sometimes you have
a clip go viral we've all had like a
joke go viral and then sometimes you're
just
finding new people and some of those new
people were like i love this i i can't
believe i didn't know this comment right
right and other people were like shame
on this person well that's the cost of
of
going viral but it's that it's also that
they have a platform now those people
never had a platform before
we have social media do they really have
a platform they they have a comment it's
not a real problem right but but they
can spread like wildfire yeah you can
that's why you can take a [ __ ] part
of a bit yeah not the whole thing
and then [ __ ] post it and be like
they said this here it is and it's like
no that's not the whole [ __ ] thing
and it's all the same thing with
politics it's like citizens united
this comic said jews are the worst no i
was quoting the guy saying jews are the
worst yes that's exactly you didn't take
the whole [ __ ] and then this is the one
which bugs me the most they go
you're allowed to make your joke i'm
allowed to [ __ ] on you and say you're
not funny that's free speech i'm like
please [ __ ] on me i don't think i'm that
funny but when you go this guy's a piece
of [ __ ] bigot right homophobe racist and
now you're ruining my career you're
ruining my name you're slandering me
that's what i'm talking about it's not
the actual hey you're not funny i'll
take that all day but it's the you're a
bad person i'm sorry i wrote that about
you i do like you no but it's also the
um
the uh you know bringing up [ __ ] from
like 15 20 years ago right and the
person has evolved like i remember i
wrote write about kevin hart in the book
it's like oh yeah the gay jokes right
and it's like they weren't funny and
they you know
it's
i didn't even think they were fi i
didn't even know where the humor was but
i know kevin right and i and i know he
apologized and i know that he has
evolved and as a as a gay
you know it's like that's what you want
you want people you like your you hope
for that right you're like we want you
to evolve we're out here to change your
mind and then when they change your mind
you're gonna bring up [ __ ] it's like
being in a bad [ __ ] relationship
totally yeah you're bringing this i mean
like it's like nick cannon he said
anti-semitic [ __ ] and he's still not
funny i mean nick when are you gonna
figure it out right right right that's
all right no but you're right about
kevin i think it's like
people have
you're not for growth if you're if
you're not letting people grow that's
what i'm saying the cloud thing they'd
rather you be a bigot and get the the
clicks then you actually evolve and
there'd be less homophobia like there's
this that's the problem
like
shade and freud about yes get out
uh we're gonna we're to use that word
about jews
but it's like we're just gonna but some
say shot them freud but it's like
people love watching people crash and
burn it's like they love it yeah it's so
[ __ ] gross where's i thought you were
so worried about hurting people's
feelings being insensitive and it's
about money oh our sponsors won't like
that who [ __ ] cares ah they're all
cowards yeah it's the whole show it's so
upsetting i'm so glad that our sponsors
are on [ __ ] all right this podcast
i'm so glad that they uh we've never had
a pulled sponsor have we no not yet not
yet
you know you know my podcast is killing
me now and the logo i've been on i had a
great time on that that name is
offensive to me i know you can't i know
so i had a
the logo was a noose with a mic hanging
off the news right yeah
and they were like you gotta get rid of
the noose what yeah see we cater that's
what i'm talking about we can't change
it to that but yeah where's the old lo
oh my god scrub i will say i will say
that people that commit suicide are
culturally appropriating lynching and i
find that to be offensive i find that to
be offensive
that's great
hey we might be drunk is brought to you
by sheath underwear i i won't even look
i bet i'm wearing them right now
oh
there they are i'm not i'm not today but
i usually am he usually is i can vouch
i've seen his [ __ ] the official two
pouch underwear of comedy fans
everywhere sheet underwear has been
cradling nuts and schlong since 2013.
who wrote this my aunt
we love them you'll love them they got
it for men women it's the best they're
soft they're sexy they're slick they're
sleek you got the balls and the nuts
separated finally they need some meat
time plus that it's invented by a army
soldier and comedy superfan robert
patton he knew there had to be a better
way to unstuck the junk and sheet was
born futuristic dick pouch aside this
underwear is comfy cool and comes in so
many different patterns you can have a
sheath pair ready for any occasion and
they didn't leave out your lady drunks
either
the comfort you guys know for your balls
sheath has applied to boobs with the
sports bras tell them how to do it fatty
while we're drinking i might need one of
them
uh go to sheath underwear dot com and
order with promo code drunk to get 20
off your first order and sheath 100
money back guarantee that sheath
underwear dot com promo code drunk get
sheath underwear and let them support
your ball bag yeah what more do you need
wearing them right now we might be drunk
is sponsored by better help online
therapy relationships take work a lot of
us will drop anything to go help someone
we care about we'll go out of our way to
treat other people well but how often do
we give ourselves the same treatment for
me
working out or buying some new sneakers
is an investment in myself this month
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to take care of your most
important relationship the one you have
with yourself
we're in therapy we go to the same guy
it's necessary clean out the garbage
your head has all these horrible
thoughts
splicing your childhood traumatic
experiences you're a wreck you're a mess
you need therapy get out the garbage
whether it's hitting the gym making time
for a haircut or even trying therapy
you're your greatest asset so invest
time and effort into yourself like you
do for other people tell them how better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
maybe you got a weird boil on your face
or something you're weird you know you
don't want to see that you're all said
yep it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours give
it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy we might be drunk is sponsored
by better help and listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
drunk
you got to do this it's it's therapy
very important take care of yourself
it's going to change your life here here
hey we might be drunk is pro brought to
you by geology geology is on a mission
to make men's skin care a breeze take a
30 second diagnostic quiz tell them
about your skin and goals and their team
of dermatologists will design a regimen
just for you that is shipped directly to
your door it's that simple geology only
includes ingredients that actually make
a difference to your skin
no junk
we love geology look at this skin we got
good skin over here we're doing all
right for a couple of booze bags we're
doing pretty good yeah i mean we're
working toward a red nose yeah right but
until then awesome until then and also
the stubble helps cover up half of it
but yeah our foreheads are solid we're
all right okay their 30-day trial
includes all four of their products
everyday face wash vital morning face
cream repairing night cream nourishing
eye cream the easy routine equals easy
results get on it fellas head to
geology.com
drunk and take this free skin care quiz
and save up to 50 off on your 30 days
trial or just click the link in the show
notes that's geology g e o l o g i e dot
com slash drunk or click on the link in
the show notes and stay 50 off on your
30-day trial geology make handsome a
habit
that's my don draper voice i like it
doesn't everyone want geology
[Laughter]
all right yeah but it's it's and look we
all [ __ ] and moan about cancel culture
cats go i don't give a [ __ ] i still do
the same jokes but it's the fact that we
live with it that's what scares me
people go chappelle come on he talks
about all right whatever it's the fact
that we're sitting there going
you know maybe delete that from the pod
take that i don't want to deal with it
is the example that people bring up
you're bringing up an arena act whose
gets 24 million dollars a special right
so it's like this is the example you use
as a guy who says provocative [ __ ] he
can say whatever the [ __ ] he wants right
he's okay right there's a difference for
the the the open micro now for the
comments coming up now who has to fail
to find their voice right failure
failure failure is how you succeed in
comedy failures how you succeed in
anything but
if you fail in basketball it's by
missing a jump shot an airborne well you
got to air ball with an open mic to find
your [ __ ] voice it happens you got to
shoot an airball yeah
it's so hard to even try out new
material because you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah you know get yelled at i'll get
blogged about right right right right
guys hear me out prince andrew wasn't
that bad
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what a clown i heard the thing about the
teddy bear too how he made his help
look this up matt he made his help
organize his teddy bears i'm like oh
this dude's definitely a pedophile
are you [ __ ] kidding me i'm not
making this up look it up even jared
fogle saw that as like what a [ __ ]
oh my god jared phone look at this
look
prince andrew's former maid had to be
trained on how to arrange his teddy bear
collection this is michael jackson crazy
yeah oh yeah at least michael jackson
could sing right dance right the [ __ ] is
this guy doing god i gotta [ __ ] read
that oh my god
how about the people who are like
mike they're lying those guys are lying
about michael j who the [ __ ] hmm i
didn't even know make that [ __ ] up oh
you didn't see the dock oh that one i
can't watch it i can't watch it it's
rough it's really rough
it's hard for me i still love michael
jackson's music but god damn here's the
thing though
i can listen to the jackson five and i'm
fine but when i hear music from that
period of time when he was like
fingering and whatever he was doing
i
yeah i don't mind hitler's paintings but
once he started to invade places i kind
of was like
[Laughter]
the jackson five oh god on the boogie i
mean i love all those songs but you know
what about all these dead people and
you're finding out [ __ ] about them now
right now what do we do this one was a
nazi and that one was a racist and it's
like oh [ __ ] i like that what do we do i
mean i love as a child i loved roald
dahl books he was a rabbit anthony i
know it's very it's very complicated
right i mean
the fact that this guy could imagine
this vivid world where a child could
live in a peach but now that jews were
equal
bummer but we're
nuanced we're complex martin luther
[ __ ] martin luther king cheated on
his wife all day long but he still did a
lot of great things like people are
complaining people love to bring that up
about martin luther king and it's always
a scumbag friend who's like you know we
cheated and i'm like yeah but he did
more than you right right that's true
but with gandhi as well but same as well
yeah
what one of the worst is bill cosby it's
like yeah we talked about this last step
yeah
sure i mean i remember
well like we all know you know cosby
well i i when i was working on rosie
i remember um he was a guest
and i remember
dozing off
hey now
i remember that
they told the whoever was going to get
him
escort him from the hotel they told them
to stay in the lobby
wow
that's great what a [ __ ] scope oh wow
damn first of all you're bill cosby and
you need to [ __ ] put women to sleep
that's what i don't get like what the
[ __ ] and
you already put it what
sleep by doing two and a half hours of
stand up every show yeah you have to
[ __ ] and also
you're yelling at these young
black black kids blow your face pull
your pants up don't curse you're [ __ ]
raping pete you're like a sexual
predator i have a theory people go if
you're one extreme way it's gonna
everything comes out in the wash
everything even right so if you're super
hyper or whatever about right right
right
it's projection baby it's like those uh
senators who hate gay god hate right and
then they all come out every time it's
like they're in a [ __ ] bathroom
putting their dick through a hole same
[ __ ] that's why these activists
sometimes i'm like what's going on not
activists but like super tweeter guys
where you're like what what's your
motivation what are you overcompensating
word i'm looking for god damn it judy i
want to ask you about joan rivers
because i know
i know you were you were friends cause
we love joan rivers we're we're big fans
and i know you were friends with her
first of all
the hardest like the work ethic
i can't even i remember colin there was
this guy
um what the [ __ ] was his name he worked
at catch
he was a chinese immigrant he never
slept he sent money back to his family
oh
what was this comic or no
no no he worked to catch as like wow
oh oh god i gotta text colin uh and
andrew yang
it was
what was his [ __ ] name anyway
he was the greatest guy but he worked so
hard he worked like three jobs and was
bringing up his fa you know his kids and
sending money to his family and colin
used to say i just want
someone with the work ethic of
right now right
and that was her and and she
like you see in the documentary she
never stops right and then
my friend gary worked for her and you
know she cataloged all her jokes she
also had this rolodex and when her
husband died and her daughter wasn't
even talking to her like that whole
horrible she's like johnny [ __ ]
carson
yeah
every other guy that co-hosted that show
went on and got their own shows and he
didn't give a [ __ ] when she went and got
her show on fox interesting it was like
[ __ ] you i'm not you know you are you
know for a woman in the 80s to get a
[ __ ] you from johnny carson right you've
got to feel like you're a doctor and if
you look at if you look at the old
videos of her on that show i mean he's
like
he's hysterical this [ __ ] midwestern
white
like you know this brash jewish woman
brilliant you know and he just thinks
she's the most hysterical thing now
meanwhile
all these other guys like david brenner
and all these other people
um
went and did their own shows with his
blessing and then she does she takes
care of herself and [ __ ] you
i gotta be honest i never got david
brenner of all this i never did either
it's like i i love so many of those
comics from that period and i i've tried
to watch a lot of his sets and i just i
know that he was a good comic i know
that he was like a respected comic but i
watched those sets and like joan makes
me laugh yeah oh my god like
like from your gut yeah i remember one
time at catch i was emceeing and david
browner walked in
and he had this white fur coat on and i
think that's why i didn't get him
there's something missing and uh what
comment can walk into my wife
and uh
he didn't want to be introduced so the
other comic would come off
the stage would be bare everyone would
be like oh what's going on where's the
emcee
and he would just walk on stage
and
you know the people would be like you
know and at the end of his act i
remember
101 dalmatians right you're going to
wear this
he would at the end of his act he would
say do a question and answer thing
you know
at the end and um
at the end you know at the end of catch
rising start like eight late 80s early
90s and uh he would do this um
anyone have any questions for me and i
remember
one night
some guy raised his hand and said
yeah who are you
the ultimate zing yeah and it was so i
mean he was a legend and he did have
that joke about the
he was famous for that joke about the
sitting on the subway i don't know his
stuff oh so he was sitting on a
newspaper on the subway
um and someone said oh are you reading
that and he
and he got up
turned the page and sat down again so
that was one of his famous
jokes but yeah he was like a big
comic of that era but joan i mean when
you think about how she had to deal with
the woman [ __ ] she had to deal and if
you look at her five decades in the
business you knew exactly where women
stood in society by what she was talking
about and she talked about [ __ ] that
women didn't talk about like getting
divorced and you know
plastic surgery it was all this
breakthrough [ __ ] and at her memorial
i mean i never cried and laughed so hard
at the same time really yeah well like
do you remember some of the oh god
howard stern went up
love howard stern another person i love
big fans um
i talk a lot about him in my book um
he went up and said
i mean you know it's in a synagogue
there's the torahs in
the ark behind him
and he says
joan rivers
had a huge vagina
and
we all start laughing and he tells his
joke and i knew it because he did this
joke about how dry her vagina was and
that if she was whitney houston she
wouldn't have drowned because her vagina
would have sucked up the water i said i
don't remember but it was [ __ ]
brilliant and you know at a funeral what
more can you want that's how you know
you had funny friends yes someone says
that [ __ ] at your funeral right yeah and
and then you and then he talked from the
heart and was
she came on my show she did everything
she was so supportive of other comics
um and she's when he was nothing he's
like i was nothing and she would come on
that show
she was really
like i think about her every single day
and as you know look i was born in 1962
i knew who joan rivers was since i'm a
little girl my parents loved her i saw
this woman who was like
sitting on the [ __ ] couch
being brash and outspoken i was like oh
my god i can do that i can and and my
parents loved her you know so it was
like
i don't know and she was brilliant
brilliant she was part of the american
lexicon like you just she just came up
like she's in like in disney movies
they'll do a joan rivers joke even in
aladdin as a joke right right right she
was just part of the even chris rock
said when she died that she was the
mount rushmore of comedy
she's great and and never apologized the
only time she apologized for a joke was
when um
willie nelson she had some joke about
him having a joint i i forgot what it
was some pot joke
and his
daughter was in
either high school or or middle school
on was like the kids were teasing me and
wrote her a letter and that was the only
joke she ever took out of her ass i'm
sorry though you know if you're if
you're willing nelson's daughter and you
don't know he's smoking weed that might
be on you yeah that's neglect but you
know the whole she used to give um uh
what's her uh tail elizabeth taylor so
much [ __ ] for being you know beautiful
and then fat
and then
imagine that and she called one of their
mutual friends what was his name [ __ ] i
can't remember because i'm drunk but um
are a little bit drunk uh thank you we
might be drunk uh
she called one of their mutual friends
and said
is she upset and he's like no she
doesn't give a [ __ ]
you know and everyone was like oh you're
horrible doing fat jokes it was like you
what do you you see elizabeth taylor
she's gained a lot of weight like it's
like it's exactly what you're thinking
of course and you're not better than her
for not saying because you thought it
that's what i don't get about the whole
thing but joan rivers uh somebody put up
a clip of her on twitter this is you
know right before she died and she was
in vegas just
you know commanding the stage going back
and forth and she was making these crazy
mexican jokes and the person tweeting
was like this is horrific [ __ ] her she's
a piece of [ __ ] she's a racist and she's
killing
killing in some theater in vegas and i
remember like oh [ __ ] joan rivers in
trouble and i watched the video and i
was laughing in my hotel room right it's
like if you went to a don rickles show
yeah right and didn't get picked on you
were like oh [ __ ] he didn't say anything
about me you know
and now right isn't that beautiful but
virgil's there's a clip of him online
and he's [ __ ] on everybody he's got
to be in his mid 80s when this happened
he's [ __ ] on everyone everyone and when
they land on him they're all like yeah
like they're excited right because he
what he did was he leveled the room like
you know better than me you're this yeah
yeah
yeah and reagan [ __ ] loved him i mean
he was
he was
really and and you could tell he had
this this caustic vulnerability
like you know you knew he was a [ __ ]
great guy right you know and that and
everyone loves me
i miss i miss that connection in the
country because you're saying like
reagan loved him and like rickles is
murdering for reagan i don't feel like
we don't have that with either president
anymore like i don't well [ __ ] trump
trump no no well trump can't take a joke
it's funny that trump got roasted on
comedy central that was bad because yeah
it's like
there's a great clip of already lying
talking about uh roasting uh donald
trump and trump is it's on howard stern
and trump is going this guy had the best
out of the night he's great right and
then and then already we tells one of
the jokes and he go and trump goes he's
disgusting
he was awful he couldn't and it's like
man if only this was intentional trump
would be one of the funniest human
beings yeah yeah but you know when trump
was like calling for an investigation of
snl like that's when you end your first
amendment you know let him host right
and also
you know when you think about i didn't
know that trump
couldn't go to the white house
correspondence do it well that was that
was the death of it right right and also
michelle wolf had the last one right i
was i always wanted to do that gig i was
always like oh my god i really wanted to
do it in a way where i feel like it
would be like
we bring people together like i thought
what was great about that humor is
disarming bring people i was the white
house correspondent i texted my age i
was like there's one gig i want it's
that because i think that's a great way
to bring the country together and and
and uh yeah i'm bummed that he kind of
yeah like boozler did that uh you think
about all the people that did that paula
poundstone stephen colbert like norman
mcdonald yeah and and colbert's was
pretty hilarious colbert is great it
shows you the power the weaponization of
comedy comedy that it is a yes it brings
people together but it's also a weapon
and if you're [ __ ] not self-aware
and have no sense of humor
you know you're gonna be
oh i can't deal with that i can't
for me this is the other thing
sitting at the cellar
sitting with all you guys you know like
and getting mocked to me is like it's
love it's an honor like yeah
what you know
even to paulo when he would say [ __ ] and
i'm like oh my god that's so fun like
you and nick can be further from each
other i know and that's kind of the
beauty of comedy is that you could be so
different and still be connected we're
bound by this weird
obsession we have right
and
you
getting mocked by another comedian it's
like a badge of honor yeah of course you
know what i mean you expect it but
having trolls
call you a [ __ ]
and you know we don't know you right
it's not funny and it's not yeah you
know it's
sorry
if i'll sit in the back table and get
mocked by you guys or colin or whatever
i'll laugh yeah because you know me
ribbing and ball busting i think weirdly
as funny as those comedy central roasts
were they almost they did play into a
little bit of that because you never
knew the person you were roasting yeah
see but they used to know the point like
they were all friends comedy central
you're like a hired gun and then you're
just sitting on something
as [ __ ] like i've hosted a i posted a
couple of um roasts at the friars club
um and they were so funny big [ __ ]
sorry i love you and gloria allred i was
the one for that one
and it was just so funny because
everyone knew each other you know
um but now it's like i'm gonna write
jokes for you and you're just going to
be mean to this person yeah right you
know this kid was killed in a car crash
give me something yeah exactly exactly i
remember i was showing to tell uh bits
that were just super dark and he was
just from a roast and he was like keep
it surface coming right
whoa like he's like we [ __ ] on people's
looks and stuff you guys are going to
get through like their family tree right
right right who died of cancer go yeah
it's true but i think though those roast
battles got really popular for a hot
minute and they were brutal and vicious
and we did a couple but i think the only
reason they were so popular is because
it wasn't censored
it was dark and i think even though it
was weird to roast people like that the
audience was like this is kind of crazy
we're seeing this because comedy had
gotten kind of neutered for a while
yeah i think that's why
um tough crowd will get on the air now
exactly exactly i mean that was such a
that was such a lovely show right and it
was just us
we get we know we were going to talk
about we do our due diligence and really
you know i mean geraldo was the king of
i mean
we loved we loved we loved her all right
was the greatest
he was the nicest i i mean i [ __ ]
loved that guy so much
brilliant
and
there was respect you know even if you
who are your favorite people to be on
the show with
well i love correct but i knew i was
just going to be like whatever you said
whatever you said what about patrice was
patrice i you know did you get along
because some people you know
say he was a little much
um
yeah i liked patrice i would i would be
on the show with him and we'd fight
um
another guy you couldn't be more
different than but that is kind of like
comedy is like the great equalizer in
that right you know right
um you know we all live in the same
[ __ ] world we all have different like
we are who we are because of what we've
lived through and what we've seen you
know you can't deny someone their own
truth and my thoughts aren't that
different from yours but i might just
say it and you don't and i'm the bad guy
right and also hanging out and being
forced to make it work with these people
like that's kind of something beautiful
that i wish the country would follow you
know like cool right we're falling apart
of the seams in this country and then
you you see in your world you're like
well it's because of i think i don't
think social media is doing this any
favors because i hate each other more
it's more spreading of misinformation on
both sides and when you're forced to
kind of be in a room with people you're
forced to work it out that's how [ __ ]
works right and there was this thing
called the truth and everyone knew that
was the truth like that was a fact and
now people you know they they have we
have such a weird relationship with the
truth now plus i read this article that
said this is my truth right you know and
it's like but it's not factual you're
just gonna ask me
putting mine in front of the truth we
were doomed right but they i read this
article where they said that people are
now you know people used to sit on their
front porches and like neighbors would
talk now everyone has a back porch and
no one [ __ ] talks
well it's weird because we're so
connected with social media it's so easy
you can talk to a guy in kuwait
but we don't talk to each other right
but it's also
so easy if your uncle your [ __ ] uncle
the conspiracy theorist and everyone's
like oh shut the [ __ ] up john go to the
basement then he can go to the basement
and find you know 100 000 other people
are like yes you are absolutely right
you know that's true also the conspiracy
theorists used to be like you're one
weird friend right right now it's like
most of the people i know have weird
conspiracy theories and smart people
yeah smart people and i'm like where are
you i know
[ __ ] from yeah i know i think you can't
have any you can have one or two but
once you have like a conspiracy theory
about everything and you want it it
might be you right now yeah
it's not like you can't really [ __ ]
cornell conspiracy theorist right here
right yeah
i think we solved all the problems were
there anyone would listen to us were
there any other legends that you knew
the comedy legends that you really look
up to that you had a relationship with
john's pretty great that's pretty big
that's huge she was was she very
supportive of you oh yeah she came to
you know my one-person shows she
i have a a video with i remember she
came she was working in provincetown and
i um
uh that was the last time i saw her and
she uh was doing two shows at the town
hall i i remember i and i and i emailed
her texted her whatever and i was like
oh we're coming you know can't wait to
see you and she's like oh my god i hope
i can
it's a six-hour drive listen you might
have to go on for me like she was so
nice yeah and so i sat i was at the show
i i was like p like she made you pee in
your pants like she was so [ __ ] funny
and then afterwards
uh elisa and i my lover went backstage
and she's like hang out with me in
between shows we had some wine and um
she said let's do a vine video and i had
no idea what a [ __ ] v i was like oh
what's a vine video it's oh this new
thing is right
yeah can we find it
imagine being that old and and still
with it oh and she knew exactly she was
never that's the whole thing of this
like
you know for a woman it's it's very
interesting
that guy comics as they get older they
still can work but women oh we don't
want to hear what you have to say but
she was never more relevant when she
died at 82.
uh it's interesting i mean well that
that adapting joan rivers vine judy gul
you know video with judy gold yeah yeah
look that up matt am i slurring
nah no racial slurs
joan rivers
preach here we go oh yeah hit on that
let's see whoa this is insane i love
this so much so the internet's amazing
well we just [ __ ] on it for 20 minutes
but it's amazing too and it yeah it is
it's up and down
kevin griffin
because those are six seconds right
and you guys gotta laugh in six seconds
that's great um she was so cool she was
the [ __ ] coolest and then there's so
many comics i don't forgot who i was
talking to the other day
who just stopped doing stand-up they
couldn't take it anymore yeah it's harsh
you'll never stop
oh i don't know
oh my god can you believe i still get on
that [ __ ] subway
i love it and go downtown with my
[ __ ] notebook like i love that we're
both upper west siders because i don't
like split cabs or like do subways
[ __ ] [ __ ] the minute you got out
of the cab
i was trying to pay for it on curb the
app
[Music]
he got yeah it was like oh it didn't go
through and i'm like oh [ __ ] you yeah
that's the worst
good for youtube the whole curb but i
just tv show you that's a podcast you
guys going back up yeah
everyone
they used to call me the leopard because
i was like uh because i would always do
spots
but um and everyone's like why are you
doing a spot it's like i don't know it's
my it's my life oh i thought it was a
cougar joke hey now but
it's my last or two nights ago was
snowing
i had a spot i'm out with my girl we're
at dinner we go back home we're like
getting ready to watch tv we're cuddling
and i'm like i got a spot wow
she hated it i hate it but i was like i
said i would do it i'm gonna go do it i
got a city bike i'm in the snow it sucks
i did the gig it was in the back of a
restaurant it was incredible right and i
was so happy i did it the crowd was hot
they got me and i went back home and she
was like how was that i was like it was
amazing i don't need you
but yeah that's comedy i mean look
there's been a million bad nights but
every now and then it's magic yeah i
don't i came off the road sunday and i
did two and neither were great and
that's a bummer that happened then i did
monday and they were both killer that's
what here's my only my advice to you
you got it
i i used to do that but now i if i come
off the road i take one day that's huge
i usually do but if my girlfriend's out
of town
i have to just i'm like i need to get
out of my spot
because if she's there i want to spend
time with her and i'll cancel right but
if she's not there i'm like i'm doing
i'm doing spots i know the same way i i
cause i'm like what else am i gonna do
and i don't work on something i don't
wanna watch a [ __ ] movie i mean i
could i still do that late night you
know
are there uh do you have any
recommendations we just wreck your book
yeah get the book what what are my
recommendations
i've watched you gotta have a like you
know like you really do have to have a
life yes you know
there's so many your [ __ ] career is
not gonna [ __ ] change your diaper oh
yeah you know
so
it you got to have a balance because
otherwise your entire self-esteem
is in this
[ __ ] that you have no control over yeah
it's like and you can't take anything
personally you could just look like a
[ __ ] relative of someone who they
[ __ ] hate it you have no idea you
know what i mean good point yeah um and
when you're when you do that you don't
have another life your life becomes just
reading comments and reading messages
and that's not healthy it's nothing this
piece of [ __ ] looks like my uncle [ __ ]
i hate this guy
the good looking one
baseball yeah it's just really it's it's
you got to balance your life out and
you'd have nothing to talk about when
you have a life yeah
you got to be in the world like you have
to go you talk about evolution in terms
of like becoming a better person but
also it's interesting to see like
evolution
to have a more interesting act as well
oh my god that's um i think we were
talking about like andy kaufman used to
like
go become a cab driver for a few months
is that right yes wow
he would take john to beat you guys in
the world no i didn't know him uh
boozler was very close with him but it's
like you know how like comics are really
funny and then all of a sudden they're
like
he's not funny anymore
besides
but you know they get really famous and
you're like it's because they don't live
in the real world of course of course on
a private oh my god you know you've got
to be a part of the people like i always
we're in a private jet and they bring
you uh caviar and they don't bring you a
seltzer too oh my god you're sitting
next to prince william and prince andrew
and also
i always say dress like the local
newscaster like if you want to know what
how to what to wear at a club or how to
because you don't want to act like oh
i'm i'm better than you you can always
look at the local newscaster whatever
the [ __ ] they're wearing that's what the
people are gonna that's where i show up
new york won
[Laughter]
new york one is something like it's
funny that's such a specific new york i
love that i love that though
i have spectrum because of that [ __ ]
oh really i love that channel and they
treated women like [ __ ] they used to
really yeah once they hit 50. not
romatory yeah they she yes
she complained yes
she's a legend come on yeah
they [ __ ] treated her like [ __ ] she's
allowed to know that remember the guy
who used to rate the movies with apples
oh yeah yeah yeah that's great oh my god
he used to come to um the comedy club
drive me nuts
he'd be like i give this movie two and a
half apples right
because of the big apple yeah and he'd
be like you know i work on new york one
and i don't know i'm like
but you know you can never give up you
know there's so many ups and downs
there's it always changes yeah you know
what i mean remember the alt scene
yeah it just
i don't know
what do you have all or images you have
to go news like romantory
uh yeah dress down our producer will you
give him a taste of beauty gold peters
yeah judy's like the police chief in
every 80s movie you piece of [ __ ] you
suck give me your pageant gun all right
okay fine it doesn't have it but
whatever what um
are there any other legends that you uh
you know there i i've i always say to
you like watch this one like margaret
smith was so
funny she's very dead pan one line i
don't know her i love ronnie
great philosophical he was deep yeah he
was great i used to watch him he had a
heart attack running running in ohio
with his [ __ ] wife
like that's my worst fear you know like
saga died on the road yeah and was found
by housekeeping like i i don't know oh i
recognize her she was bad oh she was a
[ __ ] funny she's still doing the road
no
no she's retired
yep
uh lois brownfield [ __ ] hilarious
really yeah by the way in germany
boozlers would be a great name for our
fans boots oh yeah the boozlers
it's got a comedy and a booze connection
yeah martha was [ __ ] hilarious oh
there's that i remember her [ __ ] on
comedy central being always thinking
like man it's very smart oh my god she
had this one joke um
her and ellen yep she had this joke uh
the other and she was so
she spoke
very slowly
the other day
i went to the store and i bought the
shirt
and then when i got home
i realized
i didn't like the shirt i just liked the
song that was playing while i bought it
and it was just like stuff like that
that was just
she and very deadpan [ __ ] hilarious
all right yeah she was solid
and there weren't you know
letterman had his
he wasn't a personality comic yeah he
didn't like
uh he like like wendy leibman perfect
you know another like jokes he liked the
joke yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah liebman's good good stuff
quotable oh my god i'm wasted you're
wasting it i mean i'm a little like when
i thank you i'm a little like whoa you
know ben has a game at five o'clock so
i'm gonna oh hell yeah you're gonna be
heckling you're gonna be screaming oh my
god you should hear me i'm like yes
three
i love that yeah it's exciting and all
and everyone where can everyone get your
book
amazing well you can go to judygold.com
i think there's links but yeah you get
it anywhere yes i can say that but if
you love comedy it's there's it's very
historical talks about
you know
how we got to this place
right and how we've got to [ __ ] cut
the [ __ ] i agree yeah where is the game
can we go
it's in
quincy mass oh you got to go there no
i'm watching it on stream they don't
even allow people at the [ __ ] games
now oh [ __ ] with the covet i thought it
was like [ __ ]
you know what's telling my friend about
this covet [ __ ] he's like you know what
the worst part of this is is that you
can't go 20 minutes without talking
about it and i was like i know i got to
say i appreciate people when you're
talking if they go 20 plus minutes and
don't bring it up i'm like that's the
person i want to be around right that's
guys interesting yeah
i don't want to think about this [ __ ]
anymore i know but i'm so and i'm so
sick like i leave the house and i'm like
[ __ ] i forgot my mask i'm like oh
yeah i think it's kind of winding down i
hope so but who knows yeah i think it is
too i hope so
all right well you got any dates to plug
you're gonna be on the road any road
dates
falling out or uh
in the meantime i got uh you know all
over the road but uh sacramento san
diego
uh orlando west palm
columbus salt lake cleveland new york
city you guys are [ __ ] unbelievable
oh we're all we're all over this [ __ ] uh
finally we're doing tickets
yeah uh samrol.com
shows if you want tickets i i'm all over
the place so they're you're missing some
of them there but uh oh here
more comments oh god
every time i get a [ __ ] text i think
someone died yeah i know right oh
well everyone said anna's in bob sagan
it never ends let's see what do i have
baby
i'm in columbus la jolla tampa
cincinnati i know i'm so louisville i'm
at canyon improv
i have a lot of stuff in march i have to
shoot some
kids
yeah
let's see what do i have oh i'm at fat
black [ __ ] cat whoa
do you want to know i'm trying to do new
material because i'm doing a one-person
show see i don't know like i don't
do that anymore
i used to do that stuff so helpful oh i
love the la jolla comedy store do you
still stay in the condos no the condo's
not bad i will say but i got a hotel the
green hotel the green condo in the blue
condo oh my gosh
it's on the beach i never slept better
what i had a bad experience uh
i flew in it was like a long travel day
and then i got in i plugged something in
and the fuse blew and i was like get me
the [ __ ] out of here
well i was going there in the 90s and it
was like so comfortable
i love those yeah that's a nice getaway
oh my god sidesplitter all these clubs i
used to work at but they don't i'm too
old now no they'd love to have you no
please are you [ __ ] kidding me we
love you judy i love you guys
i love doing stand up
all right oh yeah i gave mine um out to
lunch i'm on netflix check it out and uh
yeah check out sam don't even do mine
it's so depressing all right yeah
do judygold.com and see how depressing
it is
i can't wait to see it i'm doing a lot
of tv so that's good oh you know what's
crazy [ __ ] i just watched a documentary
about that actress or that director who
was killed
i did and you're in it i saw you and i
was like i was like four of them i was
like there's judy raz room i don't know
i have a lot of [ __ ] but follow judy on
all social media i think it's on
instagram is uh j-e-w-d
yes g-o-r
judy gold on instagram on twitter
following everything oh i gotta change
those photos i got new photos uh well
anyway judy it's been so great having
you oh my god i love you guys even
though [ __ ] mark norman farts in my
[ __ ] face well if it makes me feel
any better i i i hid the other six
really yeah i muffled them we lick
candles for you but it's also like they
don't smell yeah well we got the candles
here
mark's designed for comedic effect none
of this is made to hurt us no
no you know what's amazing is that
um our kit when we're in the car the
kids we can definitely tell by the smell
who's who varnished oh really yeah
that's a good mom
yeah so henry will be like that was you
i'm like no what and like henry's farts
are the more i mean yeah we all
yeah yeah i'm very mature next time
you're here we'll do uh potato vodka
oh my god yes and i'll bring you some
yeah that 1850s is so [ __ ] good bring
it on martinis what do you think
with some blue cheese olives
[Music]
we'll do classic steakhouse blue cheese
martinis no problem oh my god it's a
date thanks for listening guys remember
patreon at patreon.com we might be drunk
pod uh we might be drunk at gmail.com if
you want to email us stuff we love you
thank you new merch out there say hello
uh see you see you on the road
thank you
[Music]
you